also ihr könnt ruhig da oben bleiben
hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
gaming video ja freunde es ist dienstag
und ich habe ja dienstag als neuen tag
eingeführt für das minecraft beta let's
play deswegen befinden wir uns auch hier
schon in der welt wo wir jetzt mal hab
ich mich denn echt so beschissen hier
hingestellt ich meine ich würde gerne
mit f5 jetzt euch zeigen wie ich hier
stehe aber wenn ich doppel f5 drücken
dann es gab noch danken doppel 500 meter
das ist sehr gut ich wollte mich gefragt
was man es für alex was zum heiligen
warum lag die kacke denn so hallo das
ist minecraft beta das ist das darf
nicht länger ich wollte hier ja so
brücken drüber bauen einmal in diese
richtung und von hier über nach da wie
so lag die scheiße so behindert um das
jedenfalls zu machen benötige ich viel
mehr holz und zwar von diesen bäumen
dort hinten ich wollte gerade ernsthaft
mit optischen zoom obwohl ich gar kein
ob die fein drin habe ich töte x vorher
noch die ganzen tiere hier damit ich mir
vielleicht irgendwie eine leder rüstung
machen kann oder so hier die ich da
nämlich noch ein bisschen wolle mit von
dir fällen immer schön die bäume damit
wir gleich nämlich aus den roten platz
vier geht darüber machen können viele
hat gelaufen die kommentare geschrieben
ich soll es doch mal mit cobblestone
machen finde ich jetzt aber nicht so
schön was auch einige meinten ist dass
es ja gar kein unterschied in dieser
version gibt zwischen dem gewissen holz
das heißt wenn ich jetzt theoretisch mal
dieses holz vereinbart ja genau da
bekomme ich auch die wurden place
einfach es gab ja allgemein unter dem
video so ein bisschen so geteilte
resonanzen eingemeinden minecraft spielt
schon minecraft sind das für kinderspiel
wiederum andere meinten ja ok das ist so
old school mit das ist echt ultra
coolness habe ich hier sonntag riesigen
baum angefangen alter nein ich finde
eigentlich nur cool also das ist für
mich total old school und ich kann
wieder das zocken was ich früher richtig
cool fand kann diese schweiz was ist das
warum habe ich solche lecks gab es schon
optimal für die schachfreunde ich habe
richtig guten okay es ist apple pc und
apple macht jetzt vielleicht nicht die
besten gaming pcs aber jede version von
minecraft läuft perfekt und diese
version hat einfach wie scheiße
ich will mich überhaupt nicht als die
ganze liebe schweren ich will eigentlich
nur ganz lockere minecraft zocken und
deswegen entschuldige ich mich für die
lecks aber ich habe hier frame dritte
teilweise auf 30 fps obwohl ich mit 60
auf nehme ich werde das play auf jeden
fall so lange machen wie es mir
irgendwie bock macht und wer diese
display auch dazu nutzen um teilweise
über themen zu reden die mich einfach so
ein bisschen stören oder die mich
einfach befassen oder über die ich gerne
reden wollte der euro x oder zu gehen
haben würde wie beispielsweise heute das
thema warum legt man minecraft für die
scheiße ist ja eh nicht schön hier sieht
jetzt aber die einstellungen nicht viel
auf difficulty normal vw enorme videos
trailer des inns pharmexx es kann ich
nie mehr balance machen ist das dann
irgendwie es hat echt besser ich weiß
nicht ob das jetzt noch kurzfristig ist
oder ob wir gleich wieder ab alex haben
aber ja okay es lag wieder das ist
supertoll mein comeback serviert wir
laufen einfach mal wieder zu unserem
komischen berg gebirge dort hinten hin
wo wir dann quasi gleich die brücken
drüber bauen werden ansätze insgesamt 45
holz geholt und 16 von dem wirklich
verarbeitet das direkt mal zu den player
tiefschnee aufkommen wir haben schon
pass text das ist auf jeden fall sehr
schön wir haben wirklich keine großen
auswahl möglichkeiten von wegen jahr wir
machen das so schön und hier mit
blumentöpfen von allem was derzeit in
dieser version und ich glaube wieso geht
denn die sonne schon wieder unter
perfekte scheiße ich will hier eine
brücke darüber bauen und gleich von da
nach da und dazwischen soll irgendwie
mein haus stattfinden
aber zuerst sollten wir glaube ich mal
schlafen gehen das halt auch scheiße man
kriegt ja nicht ganz mit rechts drauf
weil man irgendwie bei nacht schlafen
will ich meine wehrt sich das ausgedacht
dass man mehr schlafen kann wenn der
mond komplett erschienen ist ich meine
wir können ja nachher immer noch das
ganze irgendwie mit glasboden machen
wenn wir genug kohle und genuss sand
haben ich bin auch schon so ein bisschen
rum dass wir theoretisch nachher alles
hier so eine riesige halle spinnen die
welt so weit dass er mehrere
spendenbriefe ok ok ich dachte da wir
eine spinne die getötet werden möchte
nicht noch creeper und noch mehr spinnen
und noch nicht gut
mein gott ich bin direkt mops borner wie
selten sind diese teile da muss man ja
glaube ich so viele spiele
lukas ist ein mops fordern natur
sind da viele spinnen also ihr könnt
ruhig da oben bleiben ich will euch echt
nichts böses tun ich will nur dann eine
fackel hinsetzen und dann ihr kunde
nutzer später darum wir haben auf jeden
fall direkten mops bonner gefunden das
ist sehr schön was wir damit allerdings
so alles anstellen können weiß jetzt und
wir können einem ob alle bauen direkt an
unserem haus grund haben wir auch noch
eine höhle das ist auf jeden fall auch
cool ich wollte auf jeden fall erstmal
meinen weg weiter also was ich sagen
wollte war das nicht das echte am
coolsten fanta minecraft für das man
somit fallen bauen konnte und ja kann
man zwar jetzt auch noch aber die sind
nicht mehr dann oldschool ich habe auf
jeden fall schon rumgesprochen hier
theoretisch alles voll zu machen mit
ihnen der glasfläche und dann darüber
dass haus und dann kann man runter
gucken und ich weiß nicht ob das cool
wird aber da habe ich so lust drauf so
ein oldschool let's play ich werde dann
denke ich mir auch mal ab und zu ein
paar kommentare von euch mit reinnehmen
wo ihr dann beispielsweise sagt luca
machendem opfern soundso oder hier das
musst du so und so machen oder hey ich
hab da eine bau idee macht das doch mal
somit das ganze dann einfach so eine art
gemeinschaftsprojekt wird und nicht nur
ich das ganze hier mache also ihr seht
schon wie das ganze hier aufgebaut ist
jetzt im zweiten teil ich werde so ein
bisschen über themen reden die
beispielsweise was mich an minecraft
früher richtig gereizt hat werde dann
zwischendurch total fehlen bei
irgendwelchen spinnen sachen da
beispielsweise gerade und werde halt
zwischendurch dann warum schmeiße ich
denn jetzt das holzweg das ganze team
wird sich schneiden und dann nebenbei
versuchen hier so ein bisschen das ganze
so zu bauen wie ich mir das vorstelle
das ist jetzt quasi erst mal so unser
erster weg der führt jetzt hier rüber
und ich wollte dann theoretisch ja fakt
ist wobei ich dann mein haus hin ich
hätte den weg eigentlich hier anfangen
müssen damit er da vorne direkt drüber
geht und nicht so seitlich eine ewigkeit
später freunde ich habe gerade wirklich
drei stunden lang diesen scheiß weg von
links nach es wird schon wieder nacht
wahrscheinlich wird schon wieder nacht
oder ich habe wirklich so lang gebraucht
gerade diesen weg einfach weg zu machen
und hier hin zu setzen deswegen ist der
jetzt direkt in der mitte und wir setzen
jetzt
sich hier direkt hier in der mitte da
oben drüber einen weg zwischen beiden
wegen kommt dann unser haus aber erstmal
müssen wir schlafen und wir haben aber
wie sollte denn jetzt kommt es an meinem
scheiß bett gehe jetzt kommen schon
wieder irgendwelche monster ins
gletschereis scheiße freunde was soll
ich denn jetzt machen ich kann höchstens
irgendwelche spiele ich überhaupt
entwickelt die normal da hinten sind
schon ändern
das beruhigt mich auch kompletter
verfolgt - spinne ich habe hier noch
fünf robbie vom irgendwie da ist noch im
zombie nahles klar das ist ja wundervoll
dass ihr alle kommen sie schnappen jetzt
ein blödes bett und leg mich in
irgendeinen scheiß gebündeltes loch von
mir schön runter graben einen schönen
volle blog darüber platzieren ihren loch
graben da noch graben ich liege im bett
und wer ist vorne jetzt in einer scheiß
wand warum warum ist noch nacht ich habe
ich hier ein schönes zimmer hin setzte
dort den block hinlege mich in mein bett
ins glück in einem blog jetzt ist auch
noch mein schwert kaputt gegangen jetzt
kommt hier alles zum anderen bei mir ich
lebe unter der erde und habe ein battle
eine fackel neben mir stehen hier kann
jetzt nicht reinkommen und auch wenn
etwas kommt kann ich mich nicht wehren
weil in skelett druck an dieser stelle
bendig das video meine damen und herren
wird das hier ein bisschen zu bunt wenn
es euch gefallen habe ich mich immer
eine bewertung freude das war eine sehr
kampf- folge ja wir sehen uns dann im
nächsten part am dienstag wieder und
schreibt mir unbedingt in die kommentare
ob euch dieses let's play gefällt und
vielleicht mal was eure lieblings
minecraft version ist wo wir dann
vielleicht hin aufstocken werden